ora gas e dai però nonstante tutto gira
sotto l'ombrellone
attiviamoci un po perché non facciamo
una bella partita e la racchettoni c'è
il ragazzo di fondo che cifra sarà kate
dai dai ragazze non me lo dico più è
questa è l'offerta che non possiamo
assolutamente rifiutare
ci sono dei ragazzi buoni come il pane
che c'hanno che i suoi giocare a beach
volley insieme allora adesso qui lo dico
se non vi alzate subito da giocare con
me non siamo piani che dai mari vieni a
fare il bagno cosa fai sempre attaccato
al telefono dopo vengo devo guardare la
prima puntata del contadino cerca moglie
di prego non mi disturba tema che cos'è
come non lo conosci quando no vabbè
allora un programma disponibile su
discovery plus ci sono cinque i
contadini che devono trovare una moglie
che gli aiuti con il lavoro che tenga
compagni
poi ci sono 25 mogli che conosceranno i
contadini attraverso una serie di
incontri dopo dice ogni contadino
selezionerà tre potenziali modi con cui
vivere una settimana e alla fine di
questa settimana poi sceglieranno la
moglie con cui iniziare una relazione
vabbè bellissimo valutiamolo ma poi non
è capito sei fortunato perché proprio
appena uscita la prima puntata
vabbè play subito l'estate troppo
stressante ma troppe cose che mi danno
fastidio
la sabbia prima cosa la sabbia
fastidiosissimo ladies appiccica addosso
poi a fine giornata arrivi di pai la
doccia e trovi sabbia in punti dove
proprio non ti immaginavi per non
parlare le ba i bambini i bambini che
urlano ma io voglio dire ma ce le hanno
dei genitori di bambini ma non ci dicono
niente sti grischun i genitori
l'odio loro sono i primi maleducati
bambini per favore cambiate lido che poi
c'è gente che si vuole rilassa andato a
giocare da un'altra parte
maria che con obama io non ce la faccio
più orsi ma poi sai cosa io soffro di
pressione pass almeno stata un inferno
sono svenuta giusto ieri guarda mi sono
alzata dal letto ho perso i sensi
ma poi vogliamo parlare delle zanzare no
perché quest'anno sono più agguerrite
del solito sbaglio o no no io ho messo
guarda zanzariera spray
come si chiama gianpi rho niente quello
è proprio un massacro ciao ragazzo anni
è un sono appena arrivato al mare che
fate vi piace mi nuovo costumino amo
vieni qua famiglie le foto che devo
aggiornare il mio feed
mi raccomando fame le naturali non
impostate perché è romano più di moda ok
come se non esistesse accorgendo dai ci
sei
ne va della fame chi fa morì far bene ci
sono tremende dal basso slanciata
ragazza li ho appena pubblicato una
nuova fucina vi giuro è venuta bene al
primo colpo non sarà questo velo di
abbronzatura oggi mi sento veramente wow
andate a vedere e commentate giusy
tesoro scusa il ritardo sono dovuta
passare dalla parrucchiera rifare il
colore sente un po che mi racconti che
mi dice qualche novità qualche cosip
mirella la via del proprietario
no io sembra ieri che non sa vincere
dove già marito nota il tempo passa
veloce assai sentivo non mi dice niente
della mia nuova borsa questo è un pezzo
unico caramia quest'anno lo ha portato a
mio cognato dall'uzbekistan pensa che ha
fatto tutto con fili d'oro 24 carati
fili sottili sottili santis una
sciccheria sa se questi questi qui mary
regalo per il venticinquesimo
anniversario giuseppe e siria fatti fare
su misura per me guarda non ti posso
dire il prezzo perché volgare però sappi
che valgono tutti quanti 40mila euro che
ha speso 40 mila a macinare elastico che
mi voglio legare i capelli per fare il
bagno a mosè tività in quelli crema
solare perché lo dimenticate se non
l'avete uni brucia ma tu non hai fame
no perché io tantissima solo che
dimenticati i soldi a casa quindi stavo
pensando non è che ti scoccia primi
pranzo dai amo farmi stima va bene ma tu
te ne vai tra tanto che in macchina ma
perché dico visto che se in macchina
perde un passaggio no
ok
cioè tu non metti potesse in solare no
c'è sei pazza ma come per te ma tu idea
di danni che può causare il solo alla
pelle ma a me non importa niente sarà
bianca l'importante è la salute la 30ma
chiesa mi aiuto l'accento più schermo
totale è che poi bisognerebbe venire a
nave sono alle stelle 8 del mattino come
tracciolino e dopo i cinque del
pomeriggio è caramia te ne pentirà
amaramente qualche anno mi dirai marina
vedi ha ragione o marino come fossero
tutte queste ore sotto il sole ma non ti
viene un'insolazione tranquillo dove
succede niente sono abituata guarda
sempre ore sotto al sole non mi è mai
successo nulla
poi il bagno e non lo voglio fare perché
se faccio il bagno poteva andare a fare
la doccia e se faccio la doccia poi mi b
sporco i piedi quando torno qua e poi la
sabbia brucia e poi la doccia fredda
sì ma appaiono meno la testa ma sei
pazzo nome di questo è legato i capelli
apostoli sono appena fatto la piega se
mi voglio la testa come dr i lavori
capelli e se gli ovo troppo spesso si
rovinano 6 tranqui io sono qui nella mia
conferenza so benissimo bob non fate che
buono quello lì non guardando quagliare
allora è quello col costumino giallo
fluo e tutti i tatuaggi
la lista è bagnino amore miglior bagnino
guarda sono anni che vengo qui che li
muoio dietro ma guarda proprio non
sembra dare segni di vita hai sposato
con due figli ma io guardo mai io ho
deciso che lo comunico ufficialmente
voglio cambiare vita
mi sono stufata di tutti questi uomini
che sono superficiali capito che basano
tutto sull'apparenza non sanno fare
nulla io voglio un uomo come quelli di
una volta
un uomo tutto casa e trattore voglio
voglio trovarmi un contadino ecco un
contadino che spal il letame sappia di
concime
hai capito brava sì ma secondo te dove
posso trovarlo così esiste un programma
che si chiama il contadino cerca moglie
lo scopro solo adesso ma vabbè ma io
devo partecipare subito guarda già lo
vedo marina il contadino oggi sposi
guarda che chi in vita ma l'acqua come
fredda tanto ma da 1 a 10 tipo quanto
odio nome friday gelata non lo si faceva
di adesso così mi viene la congestione
ma siete pazzi ma scusate ma dove siete
voi
si si tocca
secondo io tocco li po perché se non
tocco vivere l'anziano noi devo toccare
no non posso fare il bagno spero tu sei
un toccato qualcosa e non aiuta e sicuro